Und der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Was ist eigentlich in den anderen internationalen Ligen in Europa so los? Dieser Frage wollen wir im Rasenfunk Kurzpass jetzt immer wieder nachgehen und heute mit einem Blick nach Italien auf die Serie A mit Christian Bernhard. Christian, schön, dass du hier mal wieder bei mir bist.
Max, hallo, sei gegrüßt.
Ja, heute sogar in Person, ne? Du bist freier Journalist, schreibst unter anderem für die SZ, für Sokrates. Bist ganz untriebig und ja vielen Hörern und Hörern schon bekannt als Experte für die Serie A. Wir haben schon gesprochen über Juwe, wir haben gesprochen über Deutschland gegen Italien bei der Europameisterschaft. Bist immer so mein Go-To-Guide, jenseits der Alpen geht.
Ja, das freut mich. Freue mich auch jedes Mal, wenn ich hier bei dir dabei sein darf. Sehr angenehm.
Ich freue mich auch. Und jetzt haben wir diesen Kurzpass schon vor einer Woche oder vor zwei Wochen fix gemacht und wussten da noch nicht, es gibt ein Thema, über das wir sprechen müssen, mit dem wir beide nicht gerecht haben. Der Tod von Davide Astori von Florenz. Hilf mal allen Hörern und Hörern, an denen das vielleicht vorbeigegangen ist. Was ist passiert in Italien?
Also am letzten Spieltag, am letzten Wochenende, war Florenz zu Gast in Udine, sind logischerweise, wie es sich gehört, am Tag davor angereist, waren da im Hotel und am Spieltag selbst, am Morgen, ist Davide Astori eben am Morgen nicht zum Frühstück erschienen, was nach einer gewissen Zeit dazu geführt hat, dass ein Betreuer nachschauen gegen was da los ist und dann haben sie ihn tot im Bett aufgefunden und da war auch relativ schnell klar, hieß es auch, dass das wohl eine natürliche Todesursache gewesen sei und das kam jetzt auch gestern bei der Autopsie raus, also die Leiche wurde in Autopsie gemacht und es war wohl so, dass sein Herz im Schlaf erst sich verlangsabt hat, also langsamer geschlagen hat und dann einfach aufgehört hat zu schlagen.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Da läuft es dann irgendwie kalt den Rücken runter, auch am Sonntag schon, als die Meldung kursierte und er hatte aber auch ein Einzelzimmer. Das war so, weiß nicht, ob das ein komischer erster Gedanke ist, aber ich dachte mir so, Mensch, normalerweise sind die doch immer im Doppelzimmer, vielleicht hätte man ihm helfen können, aber er war alleine unterwegs.
Der war am Abend davor noch mit seinem Torhüter, mit Marco Sportiello, haben die anscheinend bis spät abends oder abends noch Playstation gezockt. Dann hat er sich in sein Zimmer verabschiedet. Als er im Zimmer ankam, hat Sportiello ihm anscheinend noch eine SMS oder WhatsApp geschrieben. Er habe seine Schuhe bei ihm im Zimmer vergessen, ob er die nicht abholen wolle. Und dann war seine letzte Antwort, kein Ding, bring du mir die morgen früh. Das war so der letzte Kontakt, ja.
Gut, und wir wissen jetzt, der Spieltag wurde dann abgesagt, alle Spiele, die noch hätten stattfinden sollen, drei waren schon gespielt, der Rest wurde abgesagt. Kannst du mir mal einen Einblick geben, wie war so die Reaktion in Italien?
Ja, es war ein Schock, ganz einfach. Der Punkt ist auch der, bei solchen tragischen Geschichten kommt ja sehr oft, werden Spieler oder Personen, die in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, ja dann sehr schnell auf einen sehr hohen Thron auch oft gehoben.
Ja, glorifiziert.
Genau. Bei Astori ist es aber so, was man von allen Beteiligten mitbekommt, dass es da halt wirklich einen, um es vielleicht umgangssprachlich zu sagen, einen sehr, sehr guten Jungen einfach getroffen hat. Also den haben alle mochten, der war auch in der Nationalmannschaft, der war ja deswegen auch zum Beispiel heute bei der Beerdigung. Heute Vormittag, Donnerstag, Vormittags Beerdigung wird auch komplett Juve anwesend sein. Also der hat schon bei sehr, sehr vielen Spielern Buffon auch eine sehr…
Obwohl er da nie gespielt hat.
Genau, er war nie bei Juve, war aber halt einfach ein großer Teil dieser ganzen italienischen Familie. Und der war einfach ein sehr ruhiger, sehr angenehmer Zeitgenosse, sehr bescheidener. Also viele große Journalisten italienisch haben erzählt, dass sie bei jeder Mannschaft – er hat ja in Caliare gespielt, er kam aus der Jugend von Milan, war bei Caliare Kapitän, war dann bei Florenz – dass eigentlich alle Journalisten, die die Mannschaften von ihm verfolgt haben, haben immer sofort seine Nähe gesucht, weil der anscheinend nichts mit dieser ganzen Glamourwelt zu tun hatte, dieser ganzen großen Fußball-Superstar, sondern sehr auf dem Boden war und auch sehr gut dieses Emotionale und die Bindungen zwischen den Mannschaften, zwischen den Spielern einschätzen konnte. Also ein sehr angenehmer Gesprächspartner, auch einer, der jetzt nicht eben oben drüberflog. Und deswegen hat es wirklich sehr, sehr viele sehr tief getroffen.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Und Juwe direkt nach dem Sieg bei den Spurs zurückgeflogen. Das erdet einen wahrscheinlich, ordnet wahrscheinlich auch so manches bei einem selbst im Kopf richtig ein, wo da die Prioritäten eigentlich liegen. Jetzt gab es noch so eine Nebengeschichte, das habe ich auch nur so mit einem Auge verfolgt. Erst hieß es, er hätte am nächsten Tag einen Vertrag unterschreiben sollen, dann habe ich gehört, das wären Fake News. Kannst du mir da noch kurz helfen? Was ist da schiefgelaufen in der Kommunikation?
Ja, da kommt dann halt oft die, sage ich mal, ein bisschen die negative Seiten der Öffentlichkeit, gerade vielleicht in den letzten Jahren zum Tagen. Es muss wohl so gewesen sein, dass er wirklich kurz davor stand, den Vertrag mit der Führung Lina zu verlängern. Das große Problem dabei war, dass am Montag, also einen Tag oder was der Dienstag, zwei Tage danach, sogar der Präsident des italienischen Olympischen Komitees plötzlich öffentlich gemacht habe, dass eben die Fiorentina jetzt das Gehalt der Familie sozusagen weiterhin zahlt, sozusagen als Geste. Und wenn das ein Präsident des Olympischen Komitees sagt, dann gehen viele davon aus, dass das so ist. Aber die Fiorentina hat dann kurz danach schon gesagt, bitte, wir bitten einfach erstmal um Ruhe und um Respekt für den Mann. Wir werden alles in Ruhe regeln, aber bitte jetzt erstmal vielleicht diese ganzen Geschichten hinten anstellen. Ja, ist vielleicht der Hektik der heutigen Tage geschuldet, dass Leute meinen oder dass man immer noch was raushauen muss, was vielleicht gerade in so einer Situation nicht wirklich angebracht ist.
Ja krass, Wahnsinn. Aber das ist ein bisschen die Folge daraus, gerade bei solchen tragischen Vorfällen hat man, glaube ich, als Medienberichterstattung und auch als Publikum, man möchte von allen jetzt irgendwie was dazu hören, weil man hat so ein ganz komisches Gefühl nach, ich muss jetzt noch mehr Informationen finden. Also ich habe dann auch Instagram-Posts gesehen von Spielen, die sie verabschiedet haben, die ich dann nicht verstanden habe, weil sie auf Italienisch waren. Und ich war ganz kurz davor, das in den Google Translator zu schmeißen, dann dachte ich mir, nee komm, eigentlich ist es doch jetzt nicht für dich gemacht, dass jetzt irgendein Journalist aus Deutschland jetzt hier, wenn es ganz ganz wichtig war inhaltlich, dann wird es mir noch mal über den Weg laufen und dann habe ich das Thema so ein bisschen weggeschoben, weil das ist ja und daher kommt er dann wahrscheinlich auch, dass das halt dann wird halt auch der Präsident vom Olympischen Komitee gefragt und haben sie noch was zu sagen und ja.
Genau, so ist es und ja, ich meine die ganze Tragik, er war 31, er hat eine zweijährige Tochter, kleine Tochter daheim, sind logisch Geschichten, die passieren alltäglich auch in anderen Konstellationen, deswegen finde ich, es ist auch immer schwierig, so ein Mittelmaß zu finden. Das Beste ist wahrscheinlich wirklich, wie die Fiorentina auch gesagt hat, den Respekt der Familie gegenüber vielleicht wirklich Ruhe walten zu lassen, das ist für alle Beteiligten eh schon schwer genug und den Rest wird hoffentlich langsam, sicher langsam, aber irgendwann dann die Zeit halt höchstwahrscheinlich machen.
Genau, dann wollen wir diese Ruhe auch belassen und so schwer es ist irgendwie über Sportliche sprechen, dann würde ich auch bei der Fiorentina an der Stelle kurz bleiben, denn die liegen auf Tabellenplatz 10, sind vielleicht vielen Hörern und Hörern noch als Ex-Verein von Mario Gomez bekannt, so wurde es dann ja in den Sportnachrichtenagenturen häufig geschrieben. Wie läuft denn die Saison für Florenz jetzt unabhängig von dieser Tragödie?
Ja, die Fiorentina ist, also man muss wissen, die Fiorentina, Florenz und der Verein und die Fiorentina sind sehr, sehr eng verbunden. Es gibt viele Geschichten auch schon in der Vergangenheit, zum Beispiel Cesare Pandelli, der ehemalige Nationaltrainer. Der kommt aus der Gegend, der hatte mal eine Phase, da war er bei der Roma-Trainer, hatte eigentlich den Vertrag schon unterschrieben und dann ist seine Frau schwer krank geworden und ist dann auch, glaube ich, ein paar Monate später daran gestorben. Dann ist er vom Vertrag zurückgetreten, was alles in Ordnung war, mit dem Verein abgesprochen war und ist dann sozusagen wieder zurück in seine Heimat und wurde wirklich in Florenz so quasi von der ganzen Stadt sehr warm und sehr innig aufgenommen. Deswegen ist das Verhältnis zwischen Verein und Stadt ein sehr emotionales, ein sehr inniges und deswegen hat so eine Stadt wie Florenz, glaube ich, so etwas jetzt vielleicht auch noch mal mehr getroffen als vielleicht andere Städte oder andere Vereine. Zum Sportlichen, ja, die Fiorentiner spielt eine Saison, die eigentlich im Rahmen ist, sicher hätten sie wahrscheinlich gehofft, ein bisschen näher dran zu sein, vielleicht an den europäischen Plätzen.
Das sind gerade neun Punkte.
Genau, richtig. Aber da gab es einen Umbruch. Die haben relativ viele junge Spieler dazu geholt. Sie haben mit Bernardeschi ihren wichtigsten Offensivspieler verloren, haben aber es aber trotzdem geschafft, jetzt in den letzten Monaten auch, muss man auch noch mal sagen, unter der Führung von Astori, der im Sommer zum Kapitän gemacht wurde, wirklich auch wieder ein sehr positives Verhältnis mit der Stadt aufzubauen. Zum Beispiel einen Namen, den man vielleicht – zumindest den Vater kennt man sehr gut – Simeone spielt, das ist der Sohn von Diego Simeone, vom Atletico-Trainer. Der ist der Mittelstürmer da. Also es gibt ein paar, das sind ein paar Junge, und die Fiorentina wollte oder wird auch diesen Weg weitergehen, wollte den sehr gerne mit Astori zusammen weitergehen. Das ist so ein bisschen die aktuelle Situation.
Die eine Frage kann ich mir jetzt nicht verkneifen. Hat der Sohn von Simeone etwas vom Vater Simeone?
Also jetzt spielerisch erstmal ja nicht unbedingt, weil er Mittelstürmer ist. Er strahlt aber schon eine sehr – wie soll man sagen – seine energische Spielweise ist auch im Strafraum zu sehen. Also das ist wirklich körperlich sehr starker und hat einen sehr großen Willen. Der weiß, wo das Tor steht und der zieht da auch hin, egal, auch wenn da vielleicht zwei, drei andere ihm im Weg sind. Also ich glaube, das hat er schon vom Vater mitbekommen. Ich gehe jetzt einfach mal davon aus, dass er fußballerisch vielleicht sogar ein bisschen talentierter als der Papa ist, einfach durch die offensivere Rolle. Aber das ist einer, der kam von Genua nach Florenz, der hat da auch schon ordentlich Buden gemacht. Also das ist definitiv einer, der auf einem guten Weg ist. Und 22 Jahre, da ist noch Luft nach oben. Also das ist einer, der kann in den nächsten Jahren auch noch sicher den Schritt zu einem noch größeren Verein machen.
Gerade bei Mittelstürmer, da horchen ja so manche Hörerinnen und Hörern sicher auch einige Vereine auf. Dann lass mal an die Tabellenspitze gucken, denn da tut sich etwas Schier Ungeheuerliches. Denn es steht aktuell bei einem Spielrückstand nicht Juve an der Spitze, sondern Neapel. Und hätten die nicht 2 zu 4 gegen die Roma verloren zuletzt, dann wäre dieser Vorsprung noch deutlicher. So kann Juve mit dem ausstehenden Spiel noch vorbeiziehen. Was ist da passiert in Italien? Was macht Neapel so stark?
Ja, also passiert ist jetzt erstmal nicht so, dass Neapel einfach plötzlich – hallo, hier sind wir – auf die Bühne sprang. Das hat sich ja die letzten Jahre schon abgezeichnet. Also Neapel war letzte Saison schon bis ein paar Spieltage vor Schluss dran, quasi zusammen mit der Roma an Juve. Und ist jetzt einfach konsequent diesen Weg unter Maurizio Sarri, unter dem Trainer – da werden wir sicher auch noch kurz drüber sprechen – konsequent weitergegangen. Die haben letztes Jahr im Sommer keinen einzigen Leistungsträger abgegeben, haben wirklich auch…
Wie schaffen die das? Das ist ja das Problem, was die Verfolger in der Bundesliga immer haben. Warum geht das in Neapel, dass die ihre Mannschaft zusammenhalten?
Weil die in den letzten Jahren gemerkt haben, dass die Chance da ist, endlich wieder diesen lang ersehnten Scudetto, der seit 1990 fehlt, wieder nach Neapel zu holen. Und dass die Stadt fussballverrückt ist, muss man niemandem in Europa erklären. Aurelio de Laurentiis ist auch ein Präsident da, ein Filmmogul, der auch das nötige Kleingeld hat. Die haben einfach zusammen gesagt, es gab in den Jahren davor ein paar Situationen, Cavani oder Lavetzi, die waren dann nicht mehr zu halten, weil die einfach so hohe Gehälter sozusagen geboten bekommen haben. Da konnten die nicht mithalten. Higuain war die letzte Geschichte, da war die Ablöse so enorm, dass sie gesagt haben, komm, lass uns das machen. Und mit dem Geld von Higuain muss man auch sagen, das haben sie sehr clever investiert. Sie haben die Mannschaft jünger gemacht, gerade im Mittelfeld und haben wirklich gesagt, komm, wir greifen jetzt an und wir bieten Juwe Paroli und das ist logischerweise das Beste, was der Serie A in den letzten Jahren passieren konnte.
Verrückt und Juwe hat gar nicht gesagt, wir kaufen euch einfach den besten weg. Das wäre ja so der FC Bayern-Way of doing things.
Juwe war es sicher auch an anderen interessiert, aber wie gesagt, man darf da Napoli auch nicht unterschätzen. Ich glaube, wenn man als Spieler die Chance hat, nach Neapel zu kommen, dann ist einem auch bewusst, dass man sich da vielleicht auch ein kleines Stück weit sportlich und sterblich machen kann. Man kann sicher logischerweise in England oder was weiß ich auch noch mehr Geld verdienen, aber erstens zahlen die auch nicht schlecht und zweitens ist da einfach diese Gruppe um Hamschick, um Insigne jetzt, wie gesagt um Rehner hinten drin. Da hat sich einfach ein Kern gebildet und der greift jetzt ganz offen nach diesem riesen Ding. Ich möchte nicht wissen, was los ist, wenn die den Scoletto gewinnen. Ich weiß nicht, was die mit der Stadt machen. Ich glaube, das wäre wirklich eine der schönsten Geschichten, die sich Fußball Europa von der emotionalen Sichtweise her vorstellen könnte.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, wenn die Zustände ähnlich wie in Philly nachgewinnen, das Superbowl ist. Jetzt hast du schon ein paar Stützen genannt und wir haben ja Napoli jetzt gerade erst gesehen gegen Rhabar Leipzig in der Europa League, wo man aus deutscher Perspektive diesen Wettbewerb recht leichtfertig aufgegeben hat. Wird das kritisch gesehen in Italien oder ist man sich da komplett einig, dass man sagt, nee, volle Power auf den Scoletto, weil das ist eben die Möglichkeit, seit 1999 zum ersten Mal wieder diesen Titel zu holen?
Sie haben es nicht so gesagt, aber es war in der Tat so. Man braucht nur das Hinspiel anschauen. Da hat Saris sechs Stammspieler draußen gelassen. Im Prinzip, sogar mit einem Tor weniger Niederlage hätten sie es sogar noch gedreht. Also ich glaube, im Rückspiel haben sie mal kurz gezeigt, dass sie das schon auch, wenn es sein muss, könnten sie das Ding auch wuppen. Aber klar, da brauchen wir nicht drüber reden, die hatten drei Tage später ein wichtiges Spiel. Vieles haben sie gewonnen in der Liga und die Brio ist jetzt einfach ganz klar auf der Liga. Wenn Napoli in der Champions League weitergekommen wäre, hätten sie es sicher auch mitgenommen und durchgezogen, keine Frage. Aber die Europa League ist und bleibt einfach weiterhin nicht so interessant und deswegen war das, glaube ich, eigentlich mehr oder weniger allen Beteiligten klar, dass sie es sicher probieren werden auf eine gewisse Art und Weise, aber ganz sicher nicht mit der Viennens, wie es vielleicht andere Vereine machen.
Der Fiat Punto Cup, wobei das ja in Italien eigentlich ein Grund, um ihn zu gewinnen. Das wäre ja wie bei uns der VW Golf Cup. Das finde ich so sagen. Und was ist dann bei Juve gerade los? Es ist ja schier undenkbar, jetzt sechsmal in Folge, glaube ich, Meister geworden und es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es völlig außerhalb jeder Vorstellungskraft liegt, dass sie es auch in dieser Saison schaffen, aber immerhin ist es mal knapp.
Gut, man muss fairerweise auch sagen, es war die letzten Jahre auch knapp. Also es hat zwar am Ende dann immer Juve gemacht, aber zum Beispiel gerade im letzten Jahr, die Roma und Napoli hatten am Ende der Saison 88 Punkte. Das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, klar. In Italien gibt es 20 Mannschaften, es sind dementsprechend mehr Spiele, aber 88 Punkte auch bei 20 Mannschaften reichen, sage ich mal, in 18 von 20 Felden, würde ich sagen, theoretisch zum Titel. Das Problem eben von Roma und Napoli in den letzten Jahren war, dass Juve noch mal krasser einfach war. Wenn man sich jetzt die Tabelle anschaut, geht es ja wieder so weiter. Napoli hat 69 Punkte in 22 Spielen, die haben nur zwei Spiele verloren. Also was die zwei da vorne bestreiten, ist wirklich sehr, sehr beeindruckend. Ich glaube, Napoli hat jetzt 10 Auswärtssiege in Serie. Im Prinzip ist das…
Neapel hat 62 Tore erzielt, 19 kassiert, Juve 63 erzielt und 15 kassiert. Also unglaublich.
Also bei Juve kennt man das aus den letzten Jahren. Juve hat einfach – da kommen wir vielleicht auch noch kurz darauf – das ist eine Mentalitätssache. Juve hat einfach diesen Modus mittlerweile drin. Sie wissen, sie sind die Stärksten eigentlich. Und da ist eine gewisse Selbstverständlichkeit dabei in Italien. Napoli hat es jetzt geschafft, auch auf diese Stufe zu kommen. Napoli war zum Beispiel in den letzten Jahren – das war das Problem ganz oft von Napoli. Napoli hat gegen die Großen – Juve hat auch schon oft geschlagen – die Großen, Napoli hat in den letzten Jahren oft Punkte gegen die Kleinen liegen gelassen. Und das hat sich zum Beispiel heuer verändert. Die gewinnen jetzt halt auch bei Bologna, bei Spal, bei Sassuolo. Die Spiele gewinnen sie und dementsprechend sind sie dabei. Also es ist schon ein Rennen auf sehr, sehr hohem Niveau, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, und die Haltung von Juve zu knappen Spielen, die konnte man sehr gut am letzten Spieltag beobachten. Im Spiel bei Lazio steht es bis in die 90. Minute 0 zu 0 und es ist nicht viel passiert. Ich habe es nebenher geguckt und konnte sehr gut nebenher noch was arbeiten. Das war überhaupt gar kein Problem. Und dann in der 90 plus x Minute die Baller mit einer Weltklasse Aktion. Auch super, wie er sich durchsetzt und dann 1 zu 0. Ja, und dann gewinnt man so ein Spiel 1 zu 0 und hat vorher die beiden Spiele auch schon nur mit 1 zu 0 gewonnen. Also sie holen halt genau die Ergebnisse, die sie bekommen.
Und das ist so ein Punkt zum Beispiel, das war jetzt auch, dieser Spieltag wird wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen in Erinnerung bleiben. Das Spiel war um 18 Uhr am Samstag. Juwe macht in der 93. das Ding. Kurz darauf fängt Napoli an und du hast es wieder gemerkt, das beeinflusst. Also das ist eine Kopfsache auch. Napoli kommt getragen von dieser Euphorie. Die wissen, dass sie das spielerisch und vom Potenzial her total drin haben, das Ding zu gewinnen. Aber du siehst immer dieses Juwe, das es irgendwie schafft, dieses Ding zu rocken. Der Romaspieler Perotti, der argentinische Nationalspieler, hat auch nach dem Spiel gemeint, nach dem 4-2-Sieg, man habe Napoli ein bisschen angemerkt, dass das ein Knacks gebracht hat, dieses späte Tor von Dybala. Und deswegen wird es sehr, sehr spannend. Also ich glaube, das spielt sich sehr viel im Kopf ab. Napoli, wie gesagt, spielerisch brauchen wir nicht darüber reden. Die können das Ding definitiv holen. Aber das Problem ist halt, können sie dieses psychologische, diese Mindgames quasi mit Juwe mithalten. Das wird sehr, sehr spannend zu sehen.
Ja, und vermutlich kommt da auch irgendwie die Champions League noch mit rein, weil die für Juwe ja so ein bisschen der Schinken ist, den man die ganze Zeit der Parma-Schinken, den man mir immer hinterher läuft. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das als Turinern darf, aber vielleicht…
Wenn er lecker ist, definitiv.
Ja, das definitiv, genau. Vielleicht kommt das da auch noch mit rein, wie weit Juwe da kommt. Und dann kann man nicht über die Serie A sprechen, ohne in zwei Fußballstädte zu gucken, und zwar zum einen Rom und zum anderen Mailand. Erzähl uns mal, was ist da los? AS und Lazio sind ja gerade so mit einigem Abstand die Verfolger auf 3 und 4.
Ja, in Rom. Also fangen wir vielleicht bei Lazio an, was ein bisschen überraschend ist. Lazio spielt eine sehr, sehr starke Saison. Hätte man sicher nicht gedacht, dass die jetzt zu dem Zeitpunkt zum Beispiel vor Inter und vor Milan stehen. Lazio macht es sehr gut. Simonen Sage, der Trainer, ist auf dem Weg dazu, einer der Nächsten, sag ich mal, großen italienischen Trainer zu werden. Die Schule, die ja dafür bekannt ist, dass da der ein oder andere rauskommt, der durchaus Qualitäten hat. Giro Immobile schießt diese Saison ungefähr alles kurz und klein. Ich habe extra nochmal kurz nachgeschaut. Es gibt in Europa anscheinend momentan in großen Ligen nur Neymar und Messi haben mehr Skorepunkte als er. Also er hat 23 Tore und auch noch die meisten Vorlagen der Serie A. Das ist vielleicht der Name, der logischerweise durch seine deutsche Vergangenheit in Deutschland am präsentesten ist. Ich möchte aber explizit auf einen Kollegen im Mittelfeld hinweisen. Das ist der Mann, auf den jetzt schon sehr viele in Europa schauen. Ich traue dem zu, dass er einer der großen in den nächsten Jahren im Mittelfeld ist. Er ist 23 Jahre alt und hat jetzt die Saison schon wieder neun Puten gemacht. Er ist aber nicht nur offensiv stark, er hat auch sehr gute Fähigkeiten und einen sehr guten Abschluss. Er hat auch eine große Körperlichkeit, ist sehr robust, den schmeißt du nicht um, den bezwingst du im Kopf-Beispiel sehr schwer. Also könnte er auch 6er sein. Definitiv, er spielt im Dreier-Mittelfeld zusammen mit Lucas Leive, dem ehemaligen Liverpool-Spieler und Parolo, dem Nationalspieler im Italienischen. Er ist wirklich ein herausragender, er ist wie gesagt 23, Juve baggert schon seit zwei, drei Jahren. Iglitare, der Sportdirektor, hat vor kurzem mal gemeint, ja gut, letztes Jahr im Sommer haben wir ein 70-Millionen-Angebot abgelehnt. Ich meinte dann so, unbedingt billiger ist er auch nicht geworden. Also das ist definitiv einer, dem traue ich zu, dass der, wie gesagt, in den nächsten Jahren einer der ganz, ganz Großen wird.
Ja, verrückt. Dann schauen wir doch mal, ob da vielleicht der FC Bayern seinen Ring und Arturo Vidal in den Hut wirft.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass der bei all den großen europäischen Vereinen auf der Liste ist.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Und was ist bei der Roma los?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Die Roma ist, wie gesagt nochmal, muss man vielleicht auch dazu sagen, die Roma hatten letztes Jahr eben auch 88 Punkte geholt. Also das klingt immer so, ich weiß, es heißt ja in Italien am Ende gewinnt immer Juwe. Das stimmt, das war die letzten Jahre so, aber es gab durchaus Mannschaften, die…
Es lag nicht an der Schwäche der Verfolgten.
Genau, nicht nur, also wenn Juwe nicht so übermächtig gewesen wäre, dann wären da auch andere hätten das Ding holen können. Die Roma hat sehr gut begonnen, hat eine sehr gute Stabilität unter die Francesca, dem neuen Trainer, bekommen, der früher auch Spieler bei der Roma war, der den letzten Scoletto auch gewonnen hat, zum Beispiel zusammen mit Totti, Battistuta, Montella, diesen Namen. Ja, sehr schöne, Walter Samuel, Cafu, also durchaus eine sehr, sehr nette Truppe. Und sehr gut gestartet, sehr gute Balance gefunden. Und dann ist im Januar das eingetreten, was bei der Roma oft eintritt, unerklärlicherweise lassen die einfach ein paar Spiele komplett liegen. Die waren auch bis vor ein paar Wochen vorne dran.
Im kompletten Januar nicht gewonnen.
Genau, richtig. Und gewinnen dann aber wieder 4-2 in Neapel. Also das ist einfach eine Wundertüte auf hohem Niveau. Es gab da, das ist in Rom, wie gesagt, Rom ist ein sehr kompliziertes Umfeld. Also der Präsident Balotta, der US-Präsident, hat vor kurzem mal gesagt, er hätte es jetzt geschafft, hat er so gemeint, stolz zwei römische Radiostationen in den Grund sozusagen zu treten. Er wird die anderen auch noch folgen lassen. Was er damit sagen wollte, es gibt in Rom eigentlich nur himmelhoch jauchzend oder zu Tode betrübt. Also eine Ausgeglichenheit im Umfeld ist nicht da. Entweder die Mannschaft schwebt oder auf sie wird eingeprügelt. Fabio Capello hat, glaube ich, früher mal gesagt, ein Scudetto in Rom ist so viel wert wie zehn im Norden, als er meinte damals, in Mailand oder in Turin. Das ist eine sehr spezielle Konstellation, sehr emotional einfach alles. Und wie gesagt, das macht es nicht einfach für die Direktbeteiligten, für die Trainer, oft auch für die Spieler. Und das Potenzial ist da. Ich meine, Sie haben J.Core jetzt auch im Winter gehalten, der ja auch anscheinend kurz vor dem Absprung war, was aber auch wieder so eine Nummer war. Warum sollte Roma den besten Spieler abgeben? Es wurde wochenlang, es hieß ja, es sei einfach kurz davor mit Chelsea, dann doch nicht. In der Zeit hat er keine Puden gemacht, weil es halt auch an so einem wahrscheinlich nicht ganz spurlos vorbeigeht. Also es ist einfach wie gesagt ein sehr komplexes Umfeld, aber sie haben sich jetzt wieder gefangen im Februar, haben wieder gewonnen. Der junge Türke Cengiz Ünder macht gerade sehr auf sich aufmerksam, der hat in den letzten fünf Spielen jeweils getroffen, auch im Champions League-Achtelfinal hinspielt. Da sind ein paar gut im Tor, Alisson, ein brasilianischer Nationalkeeper, der eine überragende Saison spielt, der wirklich eine ganz große Klasse dahinten reingebracht hat. Dazu auch Nengolan, Rossi Strootman – das sind Leute mit großes Potenzial. Wie gesagt, das Problem bei der Roma ist einfach die Konstanz auf höchstem Niveau.
Und dann haben wir die beiden Mainländer-Vereine Inter gerade auf Platz 5, aber da ist es noch sehr eng beieinander, also um die Champions-League-Plätze noch voll in der Verlösung. Deutlicher dahinter dann schon Milan, die haben sieben Punkte Rückstand auf, naja, ich würde sagen, dem Bereich, wo es dann interessant wird, nämlich dann auch Kampf um die Champions-League-Plätze.
Ja, fangen wir vielleicht mit Milan an. Milan war bis vor ein paar Wochen, ja, kann man glaube ich nicht anders sagen, mit den Voraussetzungen, mit denen wir es im Sommer gemacht haben, eine Katastrophe. Dann kam Gattuso, wurde von sehr vielen belächelt.
Also als Trainer muss man dazu sagen.
Und vielleicht auch nicht ihm face to face gegenüber, aber zumindest in Öffentlichkeit. Aber Gattuso hat es jetzt in den letzten Wochen geschafft, das Schiff wieder klar auf Kurs zu bekommen. Die sind jetzt glaube ich seit 13 Spielen ungeschlagen, sind auch wieder wirklich, sind da herangerobbt. Also bis vor ein paar Wochen war unvorstellbar, dass das Name Champions League überhaupt nochmal ausgesprochen wird. Ich sage mal so, wenn sie das nach – also das Derby, das noch Ausständiges gewinnen, dann sind die da auch mitten im Spiel. Und ja, das hängt viel mit dem Namen Gattuso zusammen.
War der denn vorher schon als Trainer in irgendeiner anderen Funktion aufgefallen?
Das ist eben der Punkt. Nein, er war als Trainer – um es nicht zu formulieren – nicht wirklich große Erfolge. Er hatte eine Zeit in Griechenland, er hatte eine Zeit in kleinen Vereinen in Italien. Deswegen meinte ich ihm auch, wurde er ein bisschen belächelt, weil es hieß, okay, das ist eine Avogaduso. Der Mann kann halt auch als Trainer vielleicht nur laut sein oder über die Emotionen kommen. Das hing ihm an. Deswegen waren auch viele skeptisch. Aber erstens, das eine ist, er hat wirklich wieder – das hat er auch am ersten Tag klar gesagt – so Jungs, ich werde den Jungs klarmachen, dass die hier beim AC Milan sind. Und das war genau dieses Gefühl, das auch die Fans in den letzten Jahren einfach komplett vermisst haben. Es gab in den letzten Jahren, da waren durchaus Spieler dabei, die können Fußball spielen. Aber dieser alte Milan-Geist war einfach nicht mehr da. Diese alten Größen waren alle langsam verschwunden. Und Catuso hat es wirklich geschafft. Und, muss man auch sagen, hat auch jetzt fußballerisch in den letzten Wochen wirklich die Mannschaft über das Selbstvertrauen – Bonucci ist das beste Beispiel. Er war am Anfang wie ein verlorener Vogel, lief er da rum. Und jetzt wieder unter Catuso ist es wieder ungefähr der Bonucci, den man von Juventus und der Nationalmannschaft kennt. Er sagt auch erschwärmt von Catuso, sagt, er kennt kaum einen drinnen, der so viel Emotion und Leidenschaft hatte. Dazu sollte man vielleicht sagen, dass Bonucci sehr lang unter Conte gespielt hat. Also das sind jetzt schon Komplimente, die man mitnehmen darf. Ancelotti ist so ein bisschen der Mentor von Catuso, hat ihm immer auch davor schon ein bisschen zur Seite gestanden. Ist auch sehr beeindruckt, wie er das macht. Und was mir dann sehr gut jetzt in den letzten Wochen gelungen ist, ist einfach, sie haben wieder diesen italienischen Kern implementiert. Also es sind sehr viele junge Spieler. Wenn man anfängt, Donnarumma, klar im Tor kennt man die fast die komplette Abwehr. Romagnoli neben Bonucci, Calabria, ein 21er Außenverteidiger, der das sehr gut macht. Bonaventura im Mittelfeld, ein kreativer Mann vorne drin. Jetzt Cutrone, der neue junge Stürmer, der knipst und knipst. Also das Ambiente zwischen Vereinen und Fans, das in den letzten Jahren sehr, sehr angeschlagen war, ist jetzt wieder, zumindest in den letzten Wochen, sehr eng aneinandergerückt.
Und super für jedes Fußball-Quiz. Die Frage, welcher aktuelle Serie-A-Trainer hatte vorher als Trainer die Vereine Sion, Palermo, Kreta und Pisa? Und dann ist die Antwort Gennaro Gattuso.
Es gibt klingendere Namen, definitiv. Ja, aber es war geil.
Passt irgendwie auch genau so zu Gattuso, so wie er als Spieler war. So hat er sich jetzt auch in den Trainerberuf irgendwie reingesneakt. Und mal gucken, wie schnell er da nicht mehr weg will.
Ja, am Anfang hieß es vielleicht ein bisschen eine Übergangslösung. Die werden sich auch weiter umschauen. Aber ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass der Mann, wenn er so weitermacht, auch über die Saison hinaus nächste Saison da ist. Wie gesagt, ich glaube, es geht viel momentan über Emotionalität bei Milan. Und das läuft momentan. Die große Nummer wäre logisch, wenn die noch in die Champions League reinkommen. Das wäre logisch auch wichtig. Ob sich das noch erreichen lässt, ist sicher schwierig. Aber wie gesagt, mit dem Schwung der letzten Wochen würde ich es nicht ausschließen. Denn – und dann kommen wir vielleicht gleich zum anderen Milaner Verein, bei dem zeigt die Kurve in genau die entgegengesetzte Richtung. Inter erklären – ich bin gespannt, ob es irgendwann vielleicht nur Wissenschaftler gibt, die das Phänomen Inter erklären können. Ich glaube nicht daran – nicht umsonst heißt Inter in Italien Pazza Inter, also das Verrückte Inter, und diese Saison ist wieder wie gemacht dafür, um das zu beweisen. Inter hat einen sehr guten Trainer geholt, ich bin – also Spalletti ist für mich wirklich ein sehr guter Trainer, hat das in Rom bewiesen unter sehr schwierigen Umständen. Hat auch am Anfang mit Inter genau das gemacht, was man sich gedacht hat, nämlich – Erste Niederlage am 17. Spieltag. Genau.
Unfassbar.
Die waren ewig weit vorne zusammen mit Juventus und Napoli, sind die einzigen da vorne, die nicht die Doppelbelastung haben. Und man dachte sich eben, genau, jetzt ein sehr guter Trainer, Spieler-Material ist da und die ganze Woche schön Richtung Liga hinarbeiten und das Ding halt Richtung Ende zumindest solide in die Champions League-Wuppen. Ja, aber dann rechnet man halt nicht mit Inter, weil Inter ist und bleibt anscheinend Inter. Wie gesagt, schwer zu erklären, ich tue mich auch schwer.
Hatten auch einen fürchterlichen Januar, was ist denn das mit den Januarspielen bei euch? Nur unentschieden, und zwar nur eins zu eins einen kompletten Monat über.
Ja, ja und gegen Gegner wie Spall und Crotone teilweise zu Hause. Also ich glaube, ein Punkt, den man nicht unterschätzen darf, das hatten wir gerade bei Milan. Bei Inter, wenn man sich anschaut, wenn man sich die Einzelspieler hernimmt, da sind da wirklich sehr viele, die großes Potenzial haben. Was aber auffällt, ist, von all diesen Spielern gibt es genau zwei, die einen Titel in einer der großen europäischen Ligen gewonnen haben. Das ist einer, das ist Perisic, der damals in Dortmund dabei war, unter anderem Miranda, der brasilianische Innenverteidiger. Und das ist halt einfach, glaube ich, was dem Verein fehlt, mittlerweile einfach diese Siegermentalität und sowas, glaube ich, das ist ja auch das Schöne, das hat man jetzt vielleicht auch in den letzten Tagen in der Champions League gesehen. Es kommt halt nicht immer nur auf die Qualität der Einzelspieler drauf an, sondern es gibt auch, nennen wir es Geist vielleicht, ich bin davon überzeugt, es gibt eine Aura, die ein Verein trägt, die das Umfeld quasi mit reinbringt und das ist hinter einfach ab handen gekommen. Dazu kommt logisch, sobald die zweimal unentschieden spielen, die Ansprüche sind immer noch sehr hoch von außen, dann wird der Druck groß. Mailand, San Siro, das ist alles einfach nicht einfach und ich bin gespannt, ob Inter es schafft, irgendwie noch mal so Step-for-Step, ein bisschen sozusagen da oben dran zu schnuppern. Also mit dieser Mentalität meine ich, dass sie die vielleicht zurückholen.
Wie würdest du denn den italienischen Fußball, der gerade in der Serie A gespielt wird, beschreiben?
Also das Vorzeigebeispiel ist mit Sicherheit Napoli. Also ich glaube, jeder, der in den letzten Jahren vielleicht ein, zwei Napoli-Spiele gesehen hat, war sicher, glaube ich, nicht wirklich abgetan davon. Also was Sarri da geschaffen hat, ist wirklich was künstlerisch sehr, sehr anspruchsvolles.
Aber wieso ist durchschnittliche Serie A-Spiel? Weil wir leben ja in einer Zeit, in der viele sehr unzufrieden zum Beispiel mit der Bundesliga sind.
Mich eingeschlossen.
Vielleicht muss ich aber auch zu viele Spiele über 90 Minuten sehen. Wenn ich Serie A gucke und ich habe aber diese Saison wirklich nur wenig gesehen, aber was mir immer wieder auffällt, ist gerade bei Napoli gehen viel mehr Spieler ins 1 gegen 1 in Situationen, wo ein deutscher Trainer sagen würde, um Gottes Willen, wenn du hier den Ball verlierst, dann haben wir sofort ein sicheres Gegentor kassiert. Kann man das so sagen, dass das einer der Unterschiede ist, auch wenn wir von so Spitzenmannschaften wie Napoli und Juve weggehen? Oder wie ist der italienische Fußball? Ist das noch so etwas taktisch geprägt, sehr auf Defensive?
Also das Taktisch geprägte definitiv. Ich glaube, das, was du hast ja auch gerade in Napoli angesprochen, ist da, glaube ich, nicht repräsentativ. Weil, wie gesagt, Napoli ist wirklich, sage ich mal, ein Mikrokosmos vom fußballerischen Her. Es ist immer noch sehr, sehr taktisch, was auch, glaube ich, aber vielen Spielern zum Beispiel zu Gute kommt, die dann aus Italien quasi vielleicht dann nach England oder nach Spanien irgendwie noch weitergehen, weil die sehr oft im Nachhinein auch sagen, sie haben sehr viel mitgenommen aus ihrer Zeit. Das ist mit Sicherheit nicht immer sehr wunderschön oder anschaulich, aber ich sage mal so, italienische kleine Mannschaften selbst und in diesem Jahr gibt es einige davon mit Benevento, mit Cortone, mit Spal. Ja, es gibt Spiele, wo die auch mal hergeschossen werden von den Großen, aber diese Spiele sind viel, viel seltener als jetzt zum Beispiel in Spanien. Also die Kleinen kommen dann halt doch auch über die Organisation, können das defensiv relativ stabil halten. Und wir haben es ja vorhin schon angesprochen, ja, Napoli und Juve sind vorne als auch offensiv beeindruckend in der Liga, aber man braucht sich es nur wieder anschauen, die haben auch nur 19 und 15 Gegentore. Also es kommt schon auch, die Defensive ist sehr präsent, wobei es ganz sicher nicht mehr so ist wie vielleicht noch vor einigen Jahren, wo es hieß, ja gut, die lindische Mannschaft steht hinten drin und schaut, was passiert. Da hat sich wie gesagt in der spielerischen Kultur, gerade in Sargis auch einer, der sehr ansehnlich spielen lässt, und der Gattuso jetzt eben auch, hat auch Milan da definitiv einen Schritt nach vorne gemacht. Atalanta ist vielleicht ein gutes Beispiel, hat nur vielleicht gegen Dortmund gesehen. Das ist eine mutige Mannschaft, das ist eine Mannschaft, die Fußball spielen will und auch Fußball spielt und das Ganze ein bisschen verknüpft mit einer gewissen körperlichen Aggressivität und auch mit einfach einer guten taktischen Grundschulung. Und da hat sich in den letzten Jahren definitiv in Italien was getan, würde ich sagen.
Okay, wir können jetzt leider nicht über jeden Verein sprechen und in der ersten Folge über die Serie A, es wird ja noch weitere irgendwann geben. Da haben wir uns jetzt auch auf die Spitzenklubs beschränkt, aber was sind denn so, gibt es noch eine Mannschaft oder vielleicht auch mehr Mannschaften, wo du sagen würdest, die sollte man sich mal angucken. Die sind auch vielleicht eine Überraschung jetzt jenseits von den üblichen Verdächtigen, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben.
Da würde ich gerne noch mal auf Atalanta zurückkommen. Also eben wie gesagt durch die Duelle jetzt mit Dortmund, der vielleicht kurz mal in Deutschland im Fokus. Das liegt auch viel an einem Trainer, da ist Gasparini, das ist ein Name, der sicher im Ausland auch nicht weiß Gott, wie groß ist, aber das ist so ein Beispiel für einen italienischen Trainer, der einfach, der hatte auch mal kurzzeitig seine Chance bei Inter, ich sage mal so. Hief nicht so? Ja, aber ich würde zu seinen Gunsten sagen, das wäre auch mit anderen nicht viel besser gelaufen, weil das war damals noch diese sehr turbulente, sehr kurze Zeit, Post-Morigno, wo einfach…
Stimmt, stimmt hier nämlich, ja.
Aber das ist ein Trainer, der es einfach geschafft hat, so einer Mannschaft wirklich eine Identität zu geben. Die haben viele junge italienische Spieler, zum Beispiel Caldara, der Innenverteidiger, Spinazzola, Außenverteidiger, die gehören schon in Juve, die werden im Sommer zu Juve kommen, die werden auch in den nächsten Jahren, glaube ich, das Gerüst langsam der italienischen Nationalmannschaft bilden. Das ist eine Mannschaft, die Fußball spielt, also das ist nicht eine, die abwartet. Das hat man auch gegen Dortmund gesehen. Ich glaube, Dortmund hätte sich nicht beschweren können dürfen, wenn das anders ausgegangen wäre im Rückspiel. Und daran sieht man, dass es durchaus Mannschaften gibt, die eben weg von den ganz großen Namen sind, die einfach ihren eigenen Weg gehen und mit einem attraktiven oder mit einem spielerischen Stil versuchen, sozusagen den Großen einfach Paroli zu bieten. Und Atalanta gelingt das zum Beispiel auch in der Liga. Weil Atalanta hat in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren immer einem der Großen auch einen Bein gestellt, die im Eimeld-Prozessor Napoli geschlagen oder Juve geschlagen oder Roma geschlagen. Also die spielen da mit und das würde ich deswegen als sehr gutes Beispiel dafür sehen.
Spannend. Und die eine Frage, die ich die ganze Zeit jetzt im Hinterkopf hatte, abschließende Frage würde ich sagen ist, ich habe die ganze Zeit, du hast immer die Träne erwähnt, also mir fällt auch auf, dass wenn ich mit dir spreche, wird auch mal viel mehr über Träne gesprochen. Das ist glaube ich auch so eine Kultur, eine italienische, so wie ich es aus der Fahne wahrnehme. Und der zweite Gedanke ist immer wieder, du nennst mir immer viele tolle italienische Talente und jedes Mal denke ich mir, da bin ich gespannt auf die WM und dann ach nein, doch nicht. Ist das ein großes Thema auch im Alltag in Italien oder spart man das lieber aus?
Ich sage mal so, in letzter Zeit ist es einfach durch die Aktualität in den Hintergrund gerutscht. Also wie gesagt, es gibt diesen sehr emotionalen Zweikampf an der Spitzel, der Napoli Juve. Sobald die Champions League da ist, ist da logischer Fokus drauf. Jetzt gab es diese sehr tragische Geschichte mit Davide Astori. Ich bin mir sicher, dass das gegen Ende der Saison, wenn alle dann Richtung WM blicken, dann da logischerweise noch mal sehr emotional hochkommen wird. Klarerweise ist das was, was den italienischen Fußball gerade dann, glaube ich, auch – ich glaube sogar, dass sie erst dann bemerkt, wie sehr weht es tut, dass man da nicht dabei ist. Auch schon davor, glaube ich, eine Woche davor, wenn dann vielleicht Champions League rum ist, die Meisterschaft ist rum und dann blicken alle dahin. Da wird das Thema wieder sehr groß aufkommen.
Ich erinnere mich auch gerade, dass wir da das letzte Mal zusammen mitgesprochen haben. Nach dem Ausscheid gegen Schweden, das habe ich vorhin vergessen.
Ja, es ist wie gesagt, der italienische Fußballverband wird momentan komissarisch geleitet. Da ist auch noch im Verband sehr viel aufzuarbeiten. Das sind die Weichen zu stellen, ganz angefangen mit Wer wird der neue Nationaltrainer, der jetzt hier auch gesucht wird. Alessandro Costa-Corta, der EM-Milan-Verteidiger, ist da jetzt komissarisch auch tätig. Das heißt, die Namen sind Conte, Mancini, Ancelotti, Ranieri, so in die Richtung höchstwahrscheinlich. Erstmal macht es Di Biagio, der 21-Trainer, da ist auf jeden Fall, wie gesagt, da blieb auch einiges liegen. Diese Wahl hat am Anfang nicht funktioniert, was wenig überrascht hat, weil da einfach eine sehr komplexe Themenlage ist.
Ja, das hat es ja schon so damals hingekündigt im Kurzpass.
Aber das ist logisch so eine Sache, dieser Aufschrei, der damals da war, nach dem Verpassen, wo viele auch gesagt haben, komm, das ist jetzt eine Chance, wir müssen da Tabula Rasa machen, wir müssen da neue Sachen einbringen, der darf logischerweise nicht verpasst werden. Also da müssen die jetzt definitiv dranbleiben und schauen, dass da die Strukturen auf den Weg gebracht werden, dass so was nicht mehr passiert.
Meine Güte, das sind bewegte Zeiten in Italien. Eine kleine Wahl steht ja auch noch an, da kann man gespannt sein, was dabei herauskommt. Aber darüber wollen wir jetzt nicht auch noch sprechen, das wird ein bisschen zu viel. Christian, bist du eigentlich inzwischen bei Twitter?
Nein.
Was muss ich tun, damit du endlich mal zu Twitter kommst? Damit nämlich unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer dir da folgen können, denn ich weiß, sie tun das gerne und dann kriegen sie nämlich mehr als nur in so einem Kurzpass immer mal wieder was von dir mit.
Ich nehme sehr gerne als Impuls mit. Wir haben auch schon darüber gesprochen. Ich bin sehr gerne auf Twitter, ich bin passiv. Ich lese sehr gerne auf Twitter, informiere mich sehr gerne auf Twitter, habe halt einfach noch nicht diesen Schritt gemacht, mich auch zur Gesellschaft anzuschließen, sozusagen. Normalerweise spiele ich aber mit dem Gedanken.
Ich applaudiere auch jedem, der nicht das Gefühl hat, er muss sich jetzt auch noch äußern bei dir. Allerdings muss ich da Tadeln den Finger heben. Sogar unser ehemaliger Kollege Flo Regelmann hat es auf Twitter geschafft, auch unter anderem durch den Rasenfunk. Also gib dir einen Ruck und sag Bescheid, dann werde ich es verbreiten.
Definitiv, so machen wir es auf jeden Fall. Wenn der Tag gekommen sein sollte, dann werde ich dich absolut wissen lassen.
Dann vielen Dank an Christian Bernhard, schön, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst. Und vielen Dank auch an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer und vor allem an alle Rasenfunk-Supporter. Diejenigen, die uns unterstützen, unter rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen erfahrt ihr, wie. Die machen es möglich, dass ich jetzt auch an so einem Donnerstagvormittag einfach hier ein Rasenfunk aufzeichnen kann bei mir in den Studios. Das ist doch schön. Macht das und unterstützt uns gerne. Rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Und dann hören wir uns wieder, wahrscheinlich in der nächsten Schlusskonferenz. Bis dahin, macht's gut, ciao.